You graduated, you got this big debt hanging over you.
You need to work in something.
I guess, I felt a little bit stuck.
There wasn't a lot of options.
I've always been really interested in fashion ever since graduating university.
I have a personal fashion and lifestyle blog.
It's something that I'm really passionate about.
More of a hobby rather than a career goal.
I look for new trends, what's fashionable that season,...
...how other bloggers and influencers are wearing it.
ASOS insiders are a really good source of inspiration.
Once I started blogging and have that outlet,...
...opportunities started to come at me.
And it just opened my eyes to see that actually there is more out there...
...and I could do something I actually enjoyed.
To work for ASOS, like a brand that I love, is just perfect.
When your hobby becomes your work, you're always excited to get in and get going.
It's literally a dream come true to work here.